[Musique]
elle est saluée filles et bienvenue sur
mon blogue vidéo le lm griot beauty
beauté mas cup et bien à chaque semaine
comme d'habitude je vous raconterai les
petites astuces et des petits conseils
pour être toujours au top même si la vie
vous a pas fait de cadeau au départ et
aujourd'hui
attention un dossier brûlant l'épilation
à la cire haute
alors d'abord la question qu'on se pose
tout est ce qu'il faut c'est pile et
l'entrejambe et je sais ce que vous vous
dites vous vous dites bon hélène
maintenant qu'elle est dans le
show-business qu'elle a fait son
émission de relooking
elle doit s'épuiser lac raquette et ben
non les filles ça c'était avant
le ticket de métro c'est fini maintenant
c'est parce vaginaux on est revenu au
buisson naturel lépi à l'os et qui on
assume son corps un peu voilà et en plus
plus qu'on a de poils est moins con
admis cause un peric voilà alors
justement aussi pour les mycoses petite
astuce consommant plus de têtes arn
parce qu'on les attrapent souvent quand
on veut à la pistache et ben moi je vous
conseillerais bien de bien repliés tous
les poils à l'intérieur du maillot c'est
filtrante protection des eaux
on n'a pas besoin de champignons dans
notre net 1 alors les filles
réveillez vous et oui il faut arrêter de
penser de croire tout ce qu'on vous dit
dans les journaux de magazines ou même
sur le blog de cette [ __ ] delory 75
qui racontent n'importe quoi
et oui parce que le rasoir c'est super
si tu sues super les filles
bah oui c'est super le rasoir surtout
sur les parties de son corps pour voir
quand on est encore habillées mais qu'on
voit toujours à l'oeil nu
bien sûr 1 vous savez ce que je veux
dire
un des trucs qu'on aime pas trop là le
dernier petit village qui résiste
bah oui c'est super le rasoir on peut
faire des petites retouches rapide comme
ça dans le métro on va pas se taper la
honte de sortir ni demande l'aide de
cire n'importe quoi voilà alors après
sinon évidemment lié à l'option
épilation laser alors là attention les
filles vous lancez pas dans des grands
chantiers
parce que l'épilation c'est pas tout de
suite c'est pas de la première fois il
ya plusieurs séances alors money money
ça coûte très cher ça et en plus c'est
pas ça marche pas sur toutes les
incarnations peau il faut le savoir
donc bas les filles comme une
incarnation de résine plus tôt face et
je suis pas raciste mais je peux rien
pour vous voilà alors moi ce que j'aime
bien utiliser pour le reste du corps ben
série bones el assir classique
voilà ça se trouve dans n'importe quel
supermarché si ce souci du supermarché
c'est bien pratique c'est pas trop cher
je suis désolé je suis obligé le répète
c'est un peu sollicité en ce moment
depuis que celui de la td à l'eau ouais
je peux pas te parler cindy excuse moi
je suis en train de faire mon tout en hd
shooting voilà jeté
je te crois cependant un pétard bytes us
s'étaient sine die non mais c'était pas
monsieur sanchez 6 et m6 sanchez est ce
que tu lui as dit passé mardi pour
réparer la chaudière parce que mercredi
ça sera trop tard parce que vu qu'il
fait froid dans quelques chiffres oui à
face reste soit je les ramènerai pas
trop parce que s'est plaint que les
acquis qui n'encaisse compenser un
signal que ça va nous coûter bonbon
tekken rien à toi alors vraiment qu'est
ce que tu avais à bricoler captieux
hasard que tu sais pas bricoler à ce
soit qui m'a demandé ça c'est toi allez
les filles j'ai recommencé quand on est
pile maintenant je compte bien la
bandelette
on l'appliqué bien un sens du poil
ça c'est important on colle bien la tire
sur la peau et après on serre les fesses
et ouais c'est ça et voilà ça se passe
comme ça et oui il faut souffrir pour
être belle les filles alors à semaine
prochaine n'oubliez pas de regarder mon
prochain numéro
allez tous